burn up now burn the fuck up dog step
back you step back hold up
body camera video shows what led up to
an officer-involved shooting in Florida
where officials say a man having a
mental health episode charged at
deputies with knives in his hands nobody
wants to hurt you can you put the knives
down the incident happened on February
5th in New Smyrna Beach Florida a 9-1-1
call came in for a man reporting that
his son was armed with knives my son was
back upstairs he was upstairs in our
house with he's got a couple knives
walking back and forth and he's kind of
scaring me in my life the caller told
dispatch that his son later identified
as 40 33 year old Michael Kolmar
struggles with mental health issues is
he threatening anyone
not really just you think she's
protecting something and he's all about
Etc he schizophrenic and paranoia for
sure who's that he's already been
diagnosed then body camera footage shows
deputies with the Volusia County
Sheriff's Office responding to the call
call martel's First Responders they
should leave and asks his father to shut
the door on them
you can hear deputies repeatedly telling
Kolmar to drop his weapons let's go man
no he's go no
put the knives down
What's it gonna take
okay put the knives down
as officials attempt
tell him no one is there to hurt him he
swears at them and calls them derogatory
names
can you put the knives down
people man
back up you rapist shut the door in the
motherfuckers
officials radio for more help calling
the situation a negotiation we're in the
middle of basically negotiating with a
barricaded subject with two knives
are at the front door right now
yes both his parents are inside and they
don't want to leave
step back you step back hold up
after that sheriff's deputies escort his
father out of the back of the home
safely who got shipping to me take him
to me give it to me give it to me
oh my God
minutes go by and Kolmar is asked to
drop his weapons again and again he
still refuses
Michael which are not down now do you
see a knife
body camera video then shows Colmar
rushing deputies with knives in his
hands that's when a deputy opens fire
[Music]
what
push out
Volusia County officials say this
incident was the second time in the past
few weeks that Kolmar has acted
erratically on January 17th officials
responded to a call that he was armed
and possibly hallucinating Colmar was
treated on the scene for his injuries
and is expected to survive reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie